字幕: Natsuki Kominami
校正: Masaki Yanagishita
デザインとは何でしょうか
デザイン家電とか
デザイナーズマンションとか
物事をことさら大げさに
言い募るような演出について
デザインという言葉が形容されますが
果たしてこれでいいのでしょうか
最近では「デザイナーズベイビー」とか
遺伝子を操作して人間が好き勝手に
人間を作っていくようなときにも
「デザイナーズベイビー」
果たしてデザインとは何か
もっとエッセンシャルな
本質を見極めていく営みが
デザインではないかと思うのですが
今日はその辺について
お話をしていきたいと思います
皆さんご存じのとおり
人間は 環境を人間の好きな通りに
変容させて住んできました
キリンやライオンは
そんなことをしないわけですね
人間だけが環境をつくり直して
住んでいるわけです
これを外界環境形成というふうに言います
人間というのは 考えてみると
環境を四角くデザインしてきました
普段気がつかないことですが
ちょっと考えてみてください
人間というのは 両方の手がですね
左右対称についていて
目も鼻も 感覚器官も 左右対称ですね
そして「立つ」という 重力に対して
拮抗する姿勢をとっているので
常に垂直方向 あるいは
水平方向に気持ちが働いている
そういうことかもしれませんけれども
自然の地形というのは
有機的な大地なんですけれども
それを四角く四角く区画して
道路も四角くして
信号をつくったりしてですね
そこに四角いビルを建てて
住んでいるわけです
そして 四角い入り口から入って
直角の廊下を曲がって
垂直に上がる四角いエレベーターに乗って
四角いドアから降りて
さらに四角い部屋に入っていく
窓も四角ですから 風景は
四角くトリミングされてしまうわけですね
そして 四角いデスクの上で
四角いパソコンを開けて
四角いモニターを見ている
そしてキーボードも四角い
出力される紙も四角で
しかも 1対√2という形に
設計されているので
折っても折っても同じ
プロポーションの四角が出てくる
こういうふうに考えると
人間はなぜ四角く世界を
デザインしているのかということが
ちょっと気になるんじゃないかと
思いますね
クモは正方形の巣を張ったりしませんし
ミツバチは六角形が好きなのにも
かかわらずですね
一方 これは人間が両方の手を
持っているということが
重要なことで
バナナの葉っぱのような
有機的なものも
人間の手でそれを半分に折ると
直線が得られるわけですね
これをもう半分に折ると直角が現れて
さらに折りたたんでいくと
四角に辿り着くという
ある意味では 数学から
あるいは幾何学から
導かれたような発想ではなくて
人間の手が自然に四角を
発見してしまっている
ということがあるかもしれません
また 丸というのもこれも幾何学的な
推論から出てきたわけではなくて
人間の手が発見した
つまり 柔らかい石の上を硬い石で
グリグリと回転させて掘り進んでいくと
まん丸の穴が開いてしまうわけですね
この石器のように
これは人間の手が
円を発見したということですね
ですから 世界の中には丸くデザイン
されているものもたくさんあります
コインであるとか レコードであるとか
あるいはマンホールの蓋も丸いですね
もしマンホールの蓋が四角だったら
対角線上に傾けると穴に落ちてしまう
ですから マンホールの蓋は
丸くなきゃいけないわけですね
こんなふうに 世界はある秩序の下に
デザインされているわけですけども
それをもう少し注意深く見ていく
ということをやってみましょう
人間はさらに ボールというものを使って
球技をしますけれども
ボールというのは科学の進歩とともに
だんだん真球に近づいてくるわけですが
もしボールが丸くなかったら
同じ動作をしても
同じ結果が得られないので
ボールゲームの上達というのは
起こらないわけですね
ですから 科学技術が進歩して
ボールが真球に近づくにつれて
人間はボールゲームを
楽しむことができるようになってきた
こうしてボールゲームを通して
ゲームを楽しみながら
人間は知らず 自然の摂理や
宇宙の原理を体得していく
そういうこともあったかもしれません
こんなふうにして環境と対話していく
そこにデザインの萌芽というのが
あるわけです
こういうことをもう少し
詳しく見ていくためにですね
僕は20年ほど前に「リデザイン」という
展覧会をつくってみました
これは日常の物品
例えばトイレットペーパーのようなものを
すぐれたクリエーターにデザインを
やり直してもらうというふうな
展覧会だったわけですね
例えば トイレットペーパーを
建築家の坂茂にお願いして
デザインをやり直してもらう
坂茂はですね
トイレットペーパーの真ん中
センターコアの部分を
丸ではなくて四角に設計してみたんですね
そうすると 写真のとおり
四角いトイレットペーパーが
巻き上がってくるわけです
これを器具に装着すると
こんな感じになるわけですね
引っ張ると カタカタカタカタ
少し抵抗を持つわけですね
これは省資源 セーブリソーセスという
メッセージになるかもしれません
そして積み上げると
こんなふうに積みやすくなる
丸だと積みにくいし
スペースがたくさん必要なんですけども
これは省スペースにもなるし
ストレージ性能が上がりますよね
とてもいいアイデアじゃないですか
これを作ろうとすると
しかしながらうまくいかないんですね
真ん中が四角いと 生産するときに
テンションがかかってですね
紙が高速で巻き取れず切れてしまう
ということが発生するわけですね
ですから センター
芯は丸くなきゃいけない
つまり物というのは 用途だけではなくて
生産性も考えていかないと
プロダクトデザインは
できないということなんです
それから 面出薫という照明デザイナー
これは照明器具のデザイナーではなくて
環境の光と闇を設計するような
デザイナーですけども
彼にマッチをリデザインしてもらうと
こんなものを作ってくれました
これは 木の枝が地面に落ちて
地球に還る 土に還るひとつ前に
もうひと仕事してもらおう
とかいう考え方だったと思います
記念日のためのマッチ
ということなんですけども
こんなようなものを
人間が掌の中に生の火を持つというのは
非常に厳かな瞬間なんですけども
そういうところを演出するために
こんなものがあると素敵かもしれませんね
バースデーケーキや
ウェディングケーキのろうそくに
火を灯す時に
こんなものを使うとどうでしょうか
そんなことを考えると
ちょっとデザインのフィールドも
少し広がっていくような気がしませんか
それからこの展覧会の少し前に
こんな展覧会も作りました
「建築家たちのマカロニ展」という
展覧会なんですけども
これはマカロニというものを
そうそうたる建築家にデザインを
やり直してもらうということなんですけども
この建築家はこのマカロニの柔らかい部分と
ちょっと歯ごたえのある部分を
設計し分ける
というふうなことを意図してますね
それからこの建築家は
少し建築家っぽいというか
非常にキュービックな 不思議な形をした
マカロニを作ってくれました
それから この建築家は
パンチングマカロニというんですけども
マカロニにパンチングカード
のような穴をあけて
そこにソースが染み込みやすくするような
そんな工夫をしたわけですね
これは「手びねり」お母さんの味
そしてこれは「おっとこ」という
名前が付いてますが
この口のところから
しゅーっと水蒸気が出たりすると
なかなか
かわいいかもしれませんね
マカロニというのは
皆さんご存じのとおり
球体だと煮て食べる時に
芯ができてしまいますから
均一に煮やすくするために
厚みが一定じゃなきゃいけないわけですね
同時に これはソースの乗り物ですから
ソースが付着しやすいように
面積がたくさんなきゃいけない
さらに 工業製品だから
作りやすくなきゃいけませんし
毎日食べるものですから
見飽きない形じゃなきゃいけない
そういう意味では 毎日見慣れている
こういうマカロニというのは
非常にたくさんの粉体から
つくられるものですから
どんな可能性もあり得るわけですけども
あらゆる形から生き残った
デザインの強者
デザインのウイナーなんですね
そんなことを考えると
非常に世界がちょっと
面白く見えてくるんじゃないでしょうか
僕は 武蔵野美術大学という所で
デザインを教えているんですけども
学生と一緒にですね
考えていることは
世界をどうやったら
新鮮に見つめ直すことができるか
まるで
生まれて初めて世界を見るように
新鮮に物が見れたら
とても面白い
世界の見立て方ができるんじゃないか
と思います
これは学生と一緒にやった
プロジェクトなんですけども
パンツプロジェクトと言われていてですね
ちっちゃなパンツを
釘抜きの上に装着すると
釘抜きにボディーが見えてくる
フォークの中にパンツを履かせると
すごい細い足が見えてくる
洗濯バサミにもパンツを履かせると
タオルの上に座っているように
可愛らしく見えてきますし
ピーマンはなんてセクシーな
ボディーをしてるんでしょうか
こんなことが見えてくるわけですが
こういうものを
見立てというふうに言います
世界を面白く見立てる
ひとつの方法ですね
この学生たちは「正しい大根」という
プロジェクトをやってみて
実際に大根の形を幾何学的につくる
ということに挑戦してみたわけですね
こういうふうな形のものを作ってみると
むしろ背理法的にというか
逆説的に大根って何であんな形をしてるのか
ということがわかってくるわけです
これは カモフラージュ
迷彩服なんですけども
都市に溶け込む服ということで
これは新宿の迷彩服ですね
実際かなり迷彩になってますよね
これは浅草ですが
赤いアクセントが効いてますよね
そして世田谷
確かにコンクリートのところには
こんな文字が書いてありますね
そして丸の内　派手な色のタクシーが
足元を通り過ぎていきますね
これは迷彩服というよりも
一つの都市の批評として とても
面白い着眼点を見せていると思います
それからこれは
スレスレのきわみを探すという
プロジェクトなんですけども
ものの周辺に四角い形を
挿入していくことで
やかんの形っていうのは
こういうものであったかということが
むしろ明確にわかってくる
あるいは バドミントンの羽根って
どんな形だったかっていうことを
非常に明確に教えてくれたりします
長靴について あんまり深く
考えたことはありませんけれども
こういう営みによって長靴のリアリティー
というのはぐっと増してくるわけですね
これも折りたたみ式の椅子ですけども
非常に斬新なオブジェクトに
見えてくるわけです
この学生は 閾値っていう
物事の端と端を見ていくという
プロジェクトをやってくれました
タバコだとすると
どこまでがタバコの太さなのかということを
端から端まで検証してみた
これはイラストレーションですけどもね
どこまでがタバコの太さでしょうか
そして 靴のハトメの数は
どれぐらいの数が適正であるかとか
あるいはどこまでが歯ブラシと呼べるかとか
あるいは ソルトシェイカーの穴の大きさは
どれぐらいが適切であるかみたいなことを
考えてみると 日常が面白く見えてきます
エスカレーターの1段はどれぐらいが適切か
あるいは フォークの歯は
なぜ4本になったのか
あるいは バスというのは
どれぐらいの長さまでが適切
合理性があるのかというようなことを
半分冗談のようですけれども
こういうものを見てくると
日常がより新鮮に見えてくるわけですね
この学生はですね
鳥の羽の毛羽立ちが
スクープですくったばかりの
アイスクリームのテクスチャに
似てるということで
バイオミミクリーという
生き物の形をですね
アイスクリームに見立てた作品を作って
くれましたけれども いかがでしょうか
あるいは この学生はですね
この軍手の黄色い線
イエローラインが
とてもおもしろく印象的だということで
そこからファッションを
つくろうとしています
このイエローラインを
靴下の上に置いてみる
あるいはセーターの上下に置いてみると
こんな感じになるわけですね
ちょっとファッションの感じが
してきますよね
それから ハイソックスとか下着とか
あるいは バッグに
黄色をあしらってみるとどうか
そして 野球のグローブとか
ユニフォーム一式はどうなんだろうかという
こんな視点を持ってみると
ただの軍手の黄色いラインが
全く別のものに見えてくるという
こういう風なことをやってみると
世界というのは新鮮に見えてくるわけです
いかがでしょうか
世界というのはちょっと頬杖をついただけで
違って見えてくるわけですね
ですから 論理や経験則ではなく
こうだったりして というふうに
世界を新鮮に見立てていく技術というのは
これをクリエイティビティーといいますね
そういうふうなものが
ロジックや経験値とまた別の
インテリジェンスとして
世界を新鮮に感じ取っていくためには
必要なんじゃないかと僕は思います
これは お皿からボウルまで並んだ
深さの違う入れ物ですけれども
どこからがお皿で どこからがボウルか
ということを示してくださいと言われると
ちょっと混乱すると思うんですね
しかしながら
こういうふうに混乱したということは
お皿とかボウルに対する認識が
後退したわけではなくて
むしろ逆だと思います
お皿とボウルに関して
ちょっとわからなくなったということが
むしろ 世界を新鮮に感じ直す
きっかけなんじゃないかと思います
デザインというのは 言うなれば
本質を見極め可視化する営みです
皆さんも 普段の思考回路から少し離れて
デザインとは何か
この鉛筆の六角形は
何でこんな形をしているのか
この床のタイルは何で
こういうユニットになっているのか
そんなことをふと考えてみると
そこから 世界の新鮮な糸口が
つかめるかもしれません
いかがでしょうか
デザインとは何か
少しご理解いただけたでしょうか
どうもありがとうございました
（拍手）